qu'est ce qu'une probabilité voilà une
question qui m'a beaucoup marqué me fut
posée lors d'un examen oral du concours
de l'école normale supérieure et comment
dire j'ai eu 6 sur 20 à cet examen
et vous qu'en pensez vous qu'est ce
qu'une probabilité je vous invite à
mettre pause à écrire une réponse
intuitive à cette question dans les
commentaires avant d'aller plus loin
dans cette vidéo
et rassurez vous vous n'êtes pas en
situation d'examen je ne vous connais
leur est pas ainsi sur 20 si votre
réponse est incompatible avec les lois
des probabilités
lors de mon oral la réponse que j'ai
donnée était l'archétype d'une réponse
fréquentes east j'ai répondu que la
probabilité d'un événement était sa
fréquence limites quand on répète
l'expérience dans laquelle l'événement
peut intervenir
et bien sûr comme j'étais dans un oral
de mathématiques les examinateurs se
sont jetés sur des détails mathématiques
en omettant tout l'aspect philosophique
ils m'ont alors demandé si la fréquence
de l'événement allait converger et oui
parce qu'a priori ça n'a rien d'évident
reprenons le sondage de michael qui nous
dit qu'avec de plus en plus de réponses
la fréquence de la réponse garçons
convergeraient vers un nombre en
particulier
en fait il ya même deux bonnes raisons
de penser que plus il ya de réponse plus
l'ensemble des sondés sera un
échantillon différent de l'ensemble de
la population mondiale et donc qu'au
lieu de rester là où elle en est la
fréquence de réponse garçons dévierait
au gré des communautés atteinte par le
sondage pour garantir une convergence
vers une fréquence limite le fréquentent
east va alors généralement postuler
l'existence d'une vraie probabilité
c'est à dire d'un nombre p objectif est
bien définis tels que si on répétait nos
observations à l'infini alors la
fréquence limite de l'observation de
l'événement tendrait vers p ce postulat
fréquentes east semble s'être retrouvé
au coeur de nombreuses réflexions sur la
science et son rapport à la réalité
on imagine souvent que la science finira
par converger ou du moins par se
rapprocher asymptotiquement de la vérité
au fur et à mesure du progrès
scientifique ou dit ainsi souvent que le
but de la science est d'approcher une
réalité objective ou du moins que cette
intuition de ce que doit être la science
est une bonne approximation de
l'objectif qu'elle devrait se fixer et
je vous renvoie vers cette super vidéo
de monsieur vie qui expliquent en quoi
un réalisme scientifique naïf est en
fait très insatisfaisant et comment les
philosophes réaliste moderne cherche a
néanmoins donné un sens à cette approche
réaliste en s'arrêtant notamment sur la
notion de structure quoi qu'il en soit
il y à de nombreux cas où la proche
fréquentes east semble plus que
justifiée nous avons dès lors qu'il
s'agit de déterminer la proportion de
réponses garçons dans une très grande
population la probabilité paix semble
alors très bien défini on peut la
définir
ici comme étant égale à la proportion de
réponses garçons dans cette population
et il semble très raisonnable qu'on va
l'approché en répétant un tirage
aléatoire d'un 1 10
du de la population en lui demandant
s'il répondrait garçons au sondage de
michael le fréquentent isme s'intéresse
alors particulièrement à des contextes
où les données semblent être tirées de
la sorte que ce soit pour les sondages
ou pour les tests randomisés contrôlés
en double aveugle temps on parlera dans
une prochaine vidéo
dès lors la question centrale du
fréquentes east c'est de savoir à quel
point la fréquence f d'une observation
dans son échantillon est une bonne
indication de la vraie fréquence limites
a estimé à quel point après 2260 vote
la fréquence de réponse garçons du
sondage de michael est elle proche de la
vraie probabilité qu'un individu qui
fait l'expérience de pensée de michael
répondent garçons peut-on garantir en
particulier que f sera suffisamment
proche de paix pour répondre à cette
question le fréquentent isme va alors
s'intéresser aux fluctuations
statistiques de l'échantillonnage et de
la fréquence empirique f
autrement dit supposons que la vraie
probabilité swaps et quelles sont les
valeurs vraisemblable de f
à quel point f petit dévié de paix et en
particulier les mathématiciens et
statisticiens ont cherché à fournir des
réponses rigoureuses à cette question
d'un côté ils ont prouvé la loi des
grands nombres qui dit que à l'infini la
fréquence empirique f finira bel et bien
par converger vers la vraie probabilité
p malheureusement cette loi des grands
nombres ne nous dit pas combien de temps
il nous faudra attendre ni si pour un
échantillon donné la fréquence empirique
f a de bonnes chances d'être proche de
paix ou non pour répondre à cette
question le fréquentent isme s'appuient
généralement sur l'un des plus beaux
théorème des mathématiques à savoir le
théorème centrale limite initialement
prouvé dans un cas particulier par
abraham de moivre mais ensuite aussi et
surtout prouvé dans le cas général par
un certain pierre simon laplace la base
en 1809 ce théorème est vraiment un
monument des probabilités il prédit les
erreurs auxquelles s'attendre lorsqu'on
estime une vraie probabilité paix à
l'aide d'une fréquence f
une façon stupéfiante comme l'expliquent
très bien la statistique expliqué
amoucha les erreurs auxquelles on peut
s'attendre ne dépendent en fait pas
vraiment du phénomène étudié
bien souvent quand le nombre de données
tend vers l'infini de façon très
surprenante les erreurs attendus seront
distribués selon une seule et même loi
appelée la loi normale
cette loi normale est tellement
stupéfiante que ce statut
ici un francis galton disait cela à son
sujet je ne connais presque rien d'aussi
athée impressionné l'imaginaire que la
forme magnifique d'ordre cosmique
expliqué par le théorème centrale limite
ce théorème aurait été personnifié par
les grecs et d'édifier s'il avait connu
il règne avec sérénité avec un auto
effacement complet au milieu de la
confusion la plus sauvage
plus grande est la foule plus grande l
apparente anarchie et plus parfaite est
sa loi c'est la loi de la déraison
à chaque fois qu un large échantillon
d'éléments chaotique et collecter et
rassembler une insoupçonnées et
merveilleuse forme de régularité dévoile
sa présence
c'est cette régularité stupéfiants ce
qui marche de données très aléatoire qui
permet aux statisticiens fréquentes east
de maîtriser le hasard les fluctuations
statistiques et les grands écarts
alors permet de dire à quoi il faut
s'attendre avec grande probabilité la
fréquence empirique f devrait alors se
trouver dans la zone principale d'une
fameuse courbe en cloche centré autour
de la vraie probabilité paix et dont
l'épaisseur correspond en gros un
écartement dont la taille est de l'ordre
de 1 / la racine carré de la taille de
l'échantillon
voilà qui permet en particulier
statisticiens fréquentes east de définir
ce qu'est une fréquence empirique f qui
contredit l'hypothèse d'une probabilité
p en tout cas selon la plupart des
fréquentes east on pourra alors rejeter
l'hypothèse p si la courbe en cloche
prédite par l'hypothèse paix ne contient
pas la fréquence empirique f
typiquement si je reprends le sondage de
michael si j'en crois le théorème
centrale limite l'hypothèse paix est
égale à 33 % auraient prédit une
fréquence en péril autour de 33 % plus
ou moins 2%
or la fréquence empirique f correspond à
40 2 % ce qui est très loin dans
l'intervalle 31% 35% le fréquentent isme
nous inviterait alors à rejeter
l'hypothèse paix est égal à 3 3%
telle est la forme la plus standard est
la plus utilisée du test d' hypothèse
sur laquelle on reviendra plus
longuement une prochaine fois
ou pour ajouter qu'il ne s'agit
toutefois pas de la seule façon
d'analyser des données pour un
fréquentes east plutôt que de chercher à
rejeter une hypothèse le fréquentent
east peut ainsi vouloir davantage
recherché une hypothèse qu'il colle bien
aux données pour ce faire il va
considérer un ensemble de théories et
typiquement cherché à utiliser les
données pour estimer la meilleure
théorie à isoler on parle d' estimateur
statistiques
l'exemple le plus courant destinateur
statistique est typiquement l'estimateur
du maximum de vraisemblance cette
estimateur va chercher la théorie t tel
que cité est vrai alors la vraisemblance
des données d est maximale autrement dit
le maximum de vraisemblance t et la
théorie selon laquelle les données sont
le moins surprenante
les fréquentes east qui étudie les
estimateurs vont ensuite souvent
s'empresser de demander si leur
estimateur sont proches de vraies
probabilités p
jeu en particulier vont se demander si
lorsque paix et la vraie probabilité tel
ou tel estimateur convergera vers paix
lorsque la taille de l'échantillon tend
vers l'infini on parle d' estimateur
semblait ou l'estimateur convergent bref
si je caricature le fréquentent east va
souvent ce présupposé l'existence de
vraies probabilités qu'ils produisent
les données empiriques
puis il va concevoir une sorte de boîte
à outils il va étudier ces outils en
identifiant notamment ceux qui ont le
plus de chance de se rapprocher des
vraies probabilités à partir des données
empiriques et en particulier il va se
poser la question de la convergence des
solutions trouvées par ces outils voire
de leur vitesse de convergence lorsque
le nombre de données empiriques tend
vers l'infini jamais il ya des gens
parmi vous qui se considèrent fréquentes
east et qui regarde je vous invite
vivement à dire en commentaire si ma
description du frais kantisme vous
satisfait ou si vous la trouvez
scandaleusement biaisé en particulier si
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
description dit le s'il vous plaît et
sinon bah corrigez-moi cédera tout le
monde à mieux comprendre les fondements
du frais kantisme quoi qu'il en soit
cette attitude épistémique semble avoir
envahi les sciences ou du moins la
manière dont certains scientifiques
philosophes et et éthicien par le des
sciences beaucoup insistent ainsi
régulièrement sur le caractère
indispensable de la répétabilité et de
la reproductibilité des expériences et
sur l'importance de disposer
d'échantillons suffisamment importants
pour se faire un avis voir sur la
nécessité d'aller chercher davantage de
données pour trancher une question
typiquement choisissant d'abord une
hypothèse à tester puis en allant
répéter les expériences pour la rejeter
ou la corroborer et même si on ne peut
pas savoir aujourd'hui les scientifiques
ont tendance à supposer que à l'infini
on finira par savoir
ok si ça ne vous paraît pas
condat le comme principe je vais pouvoir
passer aux limites du frais kantisme et
malheureusement elle me semble vraiment
énorme
la première chose qui n'est pas
forcément la plus importante c'est que
pour donner un sens à la démarche
le fréquentent east doit commencer par
présupposés l'existence de vraies
probabilités
dans de nombreux cas comme on l'a vu
c'est une hypothèse très raisonnable est
très utile mais de là à dire qu'elle est
vrai et qu'il faut absolument raisonner
avec cette hypothèse il ya un pas à
faire ou à ne pas faire par exemple est
ce qu'il ya une vraie probabilité qu'une
réponse aux tweets de michael soit
garçon est ce que cette question a
vraiment un sens ne dépend elle pas
fortement de l'ensemble des sondés que
l'on considère de leur éducation et du
contexte dans lequel ils répondent à
cette question et cette probabilité est
elle vraiment un objet d'étude
pertinents par exemple monsieur villach
reproduit le sondage dominical launay
sur sa chaîne mais il a obtenu des
résultats significativement différent
est ce qu'il existe donc une vraie
probabilité que monsieur fille et
mickaël ont vraiment cherché à estimer
or de nombreux outils comme les
intervalles de confiance sont utilisés
pour ensuite déterminer où la
probabilité recherché a de bonnes
chances d'être sachant que cette
probabilité n'est qu'une entité postuler
par le modèle la prépondérance de ce
genre d' approche à agacer certains
scientifiques comme le statisticien
william p ex
dans un article intitulé il est temps
d'arrêter d'enseigner le fréquentent
isme ou non statisticiens brixi écrit
tout ce qu'on peut dire à propos dans
l'intervalle de confiance c'est qu'un
paramètre métaphysique peut soit si
trouver soi ne pas s'y trouver
bon je trouve la critique un peu dur
mais elle ne me semble pas sans
fondement un autre argument important
contre le fréquentent isme et qui a
tendance à négliger la prise en compte
des préjugés ou dit autrement de l'état
actuel des connaissances c'est un point
extrêmement important qui j'ai le mental
a déjà abordé dans cette vidéo mais je
vais la laisser de côté pour aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faudra vraiment prendre le
temps de le développer pour le rendre
convaincant
enfin l'argument sur lequel je compte
m'attarder pour finir cet épisode est le
suivant parce qu'ils s'intéressent à des
fréquences le fréquentent east va
s'intéresser uniquement à des événements
qui peuvent donner lieu à la notion de
fréquences d'observation et à bien y
réfléchir ceci exclut de nombreux champs
d'étude que les scientifiques jugent
généralement digne d'intérêt pour les
sciences c'est le cas par exemple du
changement climatique
à quelle fréquence at on observé un
réchauffement climatique d'origine
anthropique
quelle est la fréquence d'observation de
cet événement
il semble que cette question n'a pas de
sens de façon plus générale toute étude
de phénomènes fortement dépendant de
l'état physique de l'univers passé
présent ou futur semble difficile à
interpréter en terme de fréquence
d'observation comment expliquer la chute
de l'empiré romain
sachant qu'on ne pourra pas observé
plusieurs fois cet événement comment
étudier l'évolution du vivant sachant
qu'on ne dispose que de l'unique cas de
son évolution sur terre comment
appliquer le free kantisme à la
cosmologie sachant qu'on ne pourra pas
répéter le big bang et surtout que
peut-on dire aujourd'hui du futur
notamment des événements potentiellement
inédit du futur vu qu'aucune donnée du
futur n'est disponible
une anecdote illustre particulièrement
bien ce cas où lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale un économiste de mandat
aux statisticiens david blackwell alors
fréquentes east quelle était la
probabilité d'une guerre nucléaire
dans les cinq années à venir blackwell
répondit aux cette question n'a aucun
sens
les probabilités ça pique à de longues
séquences d'événements répétable quand
il s'agit clairement la drica unique
la probabilité est soit 0 soit 1 mais
nous ne serons pas avant cinq ans
l'économiste rétorqua j'avais peur que
vous disiez cela j'ai parlé à plusieurs
autres statisticiens et ils m'ont tous
dit la même chose
le langage du frais kantisme semble
l'empêcher d'envisager des événements
inédits du futur et il arrive parfois
que certains conclu que ne pouvant rien
dire du futur il est préférable de ne
pas en parler
il ya vraiment beaucoup d'hostilité
vis-à-vis de d'auteurs comme nick
bostrom
ou encore pirelli dukovski dont
s'inspire ningbo ce tronçon assez vite
évacué d'un revers de la main comme
étant des chars la tannerie et des
spéculations sont sans aucun intérêt le
fonds de l'objection général est aussi
toujours à dire nés quelque part voilà
sur ces deux premières questions ses
deux frères probabilité c'est trop
faible ou alors en fait souvent c'est
plutôt très difficile à évaluer
georges c'est plutôt sain suivi de et
toute façon si tout ça est un peu plus
compliqué que ça et honnêtement on n'en
sait rien voilà c'est toujours une
espèce de mélange de ça et tout ça qui
voilà qui conduit au final à sur la
dernière question mais on s'en fout
complètement parce que voilà les fois
précédentes rennes que on s'en fout
c'est vrai c'est quasi religieux vous
êtes des espèces de boubous arrêté
d'annoncer la fin du monde est
voilà est un charlatan singularisme
voilà qui contraste beaucoup avec de
nombreux bayésiens qui sont souvent
effrayés par les risques d'événements
futurs sans précédent n'ont pas car il
pense qu'il est probable que le futur
aille mal mais souvent de nombreux
arguments heuristique suggère qui n'est
pas complètement improbable que les
choses se passent mal en particulier le
fameux ordre cosmique décrit par galton
est célébrée par bien des fréquentes
east semble en fait ne s'appliquait qu'à
un petit ensemble de problèmes à savoir
ceux qui permettent la répétabilité d'un
phénomène à l'infini cependant les
expériences souvent fait davantage
reproduite dans la bo de recherche à
l'autre avec des outils et des
environnements qui ne cessent de
différer un phénomène est rarement
vraiment répétable et il ne l'est
certainement pas à l'infini mais surtout
l'ordre cosmique et de galles tonnes
n'est valable que pour des données
indépendantes est identiquement
distribuer encore une fois dans bien des
cas notamment les tests randomisée en
double aveugle ton par adam prochain
épisode
cette hypothèse est raisonnable mais
dans de nombreux cas cette hypothèse est
en fait plus que discutable en
particulier de plus en plus notamment
via la prolifération de toutes sortes de
capteurs de données et l'analyse des
données collectées de manière non
contrôlée
cette hypothèse n'est pas satisfaite les
données empiriques ressemble de plus en
plus un foutoir avec des corrélations à
tout va elles ne sont pas indépendants
est identiquement distribués et
malheureusement le réflexe du pur
fréquentes east c'est de rejeter la
pertinence de ces données ces données ne
sont pas aux standards des tests
randomisée en double aveugle que le
fréquentent east préconise et il a
raison
cependant parce qu'elles sont beaucoup
plus volumineuse mais également parce
qu'elles correspondent à des
comportements irl ces données empiriques
seront potentiellement beaucoup plus
informative que les données collectées
dans l'environnement très artificielle
du laboratoire en tout cas il semblerait
peut-être un peu irrationnel de les
jeter à la poubelle sous prétexte qu
elles n'obéissent pas aux formalismes
fréquentes east pire le plus gros danger
et ce sera de s'autoriser à ne pas
parler de certains sujets sous prétexte
qu aucune analyse répondant aux cadres
très rigide du frais kantisme n'est
possible le problème quand on tue et
discussions dans l'oeuf à grands coups
de scientifiques c'est que ça revient à
dire on sait pas donc on s'en fout mais
on s'en fout complètement parce que
voilà
les fonds précédent entre elles que on
s'en fout analysons cette phrase de plus
près déjà on sait pas ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas assez de données pour appliquer
la méthode scientifique mais dans ce cas
la question ne devrait pas être de
savoir ou de ne pas savoir mais plutôt
qu'elle la crédence peut-on avoir en
cette théorie mais le plus problématique
c'est la conclusion on s'en fout parce
que en plus de relever d'une certaine
paresse intellectuelle
cela revient à occulter complètement un
grand nombre de questions importantes
comme par exemple des questions dont
l'enjeu pour être je ne sais pas la
survie de l'humanité ce réflexe de dire
ce n'est pas scientifique est selon moi
une mauvaise habitude qui découle de la
manière dont on nous enseigne les
sciences comme si la science était une
sorte de statue grecque aux proportions
parfaites
alors qu'elle est en fait le résultat
d'un grand nombre de herman et de remise
en question et cela mais certaines
personnes dans une situation d'excès de
confiance où elles vont trouver une
sorte de valorisation sociale a cassé
tout ce qui serait pas scientifique avec
parfois un petit ricanements méprisant
ce qui n'est pas exactement une attitude
bienveillante de recherche humble de la
connaissance et qui va tuer dans l'oeuf
de nombreuses discussions sur des sujets
importants
nous avons d'énormes enjeux devant nous
et il nous faut être capable de bien les
adresser même si les données dont nous
en disposons sont bordéliques et pas
franchement indépendante est
identiquement distribués voilà pourquoi
selon briggs en tout cas il semble
peut-être temps de dépasser le cadre
restreint du frais kantisme et de songer
à des alternatives qui proposent des
traitements plus universel des données
comme le balsa nisme la fin on a parlé
de trois variantes mike de problèmes des
deux enfants et notamment y aura plein
d'autres vous invitant à tourner et se
prennent dans tous les sens et réfléchir
à tout ce qui peut y avoir deux contre
intuitif et surtout a essayé de
l'agresser tous les cas possible essayez
d'imaginer comment il faut réfléchir
dans tel ou tel cas ariel sardou fait
remarquer que par hasard en fait il une
autre chaîne anglophone médor prep qui a
fait des vidéos à ce sujet que je
recommande vivement c'est vraiment des
super vidéo
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec tout ce qui est dit dans ces vidéos
comment je pense que le raisonnement
global et pas forcément très béliziens
mais je trouve absolument génial ces
vidéos ça fait réfléchir
surtout je trouve que meilleur prête à
une approche extrêmement enthousiasmante
également très modeste du problème que
je trouve absolument adorable vraiment
je pense que c'est vraiment l'attitude
dans laquelle j'aimerais voir plus de
gens réfléchir à toutes sortes de
problèmes mathématiques et ailleurs
particulier aux médias reprennent a fait
deux vidéos et dans la deuxième il
corrige en fait des choses qui a dit
dans la première et monsieur fils
également sorti une deuxième vidéo sur
le paradoxe des deux enfants que nous
invite également vivement allez voir il
ya beaucoup de choses très très
intéressante et en baignant un peu plus
dans tous ces arguments des uns et des
autres je pense que ça peut vraiment
aider à mieux réfléchir à ce problème
est vraiment mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe vraiment particulier point un peu
mieux aider à caracter ce qui se passe
je veux rebondir au commentaire de beaux
benz cuisine qui propose un dialogue où
on semble passer d'un tiers à
retiennent quasiment un demi suite à
l'apprentissage du fait que l'un des
garçons il n'est un mardi en fait si
vous regardez un petit peu le dialogue
qui va proposer en fait dans ce cas là
non il ne faudrait pas passer à 1 2 me
est en fait ils d'incohérences un peu
dans cette histoire puisque on suppose
que l'homme a deux enfants et que donc
le moins l'un des enfants est un garçon
mais ensuite l'une des questions c est
ce que le premier est né un mardi en
fait cette question est un petit peu en
milieu parce qu'elle présuppose que le
premier du coup serait un garçon alors
qu'on ne sait pas d'une petite
incohérence ici en fait si on apprend
que le premier des enfants est un garçon
en gros ça dépend encore une fois du
contexte mais en gros la priorité que le
deuxième sera un garçon est probablement
un demi qu'en face ça dépend un petit
peu du contexte la manière dont on
apprend cette information en fait ce
truc qui est vraiment perturbant et qui
fait que ça va passer à 13 1 7e c'est
lorsque l'on répond à la question il ya
au moins un enfant né un mardi on ne
sait toujours pas le duquel on parle en
fait lorsqu'on pose cette question le
père d'une certaine manière à le
possibilité de choisir si jamais il
avait deux enfants duquel des deux
enfants il va parler c'est vraiment
cette ambiguïté sur lequel des deux
enfants on parle notamment dans le cas
où le père a deux garçons qui fait qu'
on a toutes ces bizarreries donc tous
invités un peu réfléchir un peu à ça et
à un firmament finalement à ce biais de
sélection du père qui va d'une certaine
un devoir choisir duquel de ses enfants
il va parler et ça ça m'amène au cas
plus générale ou lorsque le père dit de
lui-même
j'ai un garçon en fait il ya vraiment la
question de pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
parlent d'un enfant plutôt que de
l'autre et en particulier s'ils avaient
garçons filles
est-ce qu'il est plus probable qu'il se
met tout à coup à parler du garçon ou
qu'ils se mettent à parler de la fille
on a envie de dire qu'après c'est 50 50
mais en général à cause du contexte ce
ne sera pas 50 50 il ya des contextes
dans lesquels peut-être que le père va
davantage mettre en avant son garçon ou
peut-être que notre contexte il va
mettre davantage en avant une des filles
qu'il a en tout cas ce biais de
sélection cette probabilité qu'il se met
à parler de l'un des enfants plutôt que
de l'autre c'est vraiment le noeud du
problème ce qui fait que la réponse est
quelque part entre 0 et 1 2 me et que si
on connaît pas le contexte dans lequel
le père a choisi de parler d'un enfant
plutôt que de l'autre alors ne pourra
pas avoir la même conclusion qu'une
benzène qui elle connaîtrait le contexte
dans lequel le père a choisi de parler
lui l'un de ses enfants plutôt que de
l'autre sinon je vois bien dire que de
façon un peu général j'étais un petit
peu déçue par la virulence un peu dans
les commentaires sur ce genre de
problème ces déboires de problème je
pense qu'on est une réduction très forte
et qu'on a l'intuition très très forte
on a tendance à être un mode un peu
rationalisation raisonnement motivé à
vouloir défendre notre position et je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment dommage donc
typiquement sur ce genre de questions
c'est l'occasion d'appliquer hashtag des
bâtons mieux fait attention à ce que
vous faites surtout éviter l'auto
promotion typiquement et essayer d'être
vraiment bienveillant envers toutes les
personnes qui réfléchissent à ce
problème comme l'a été par exemple
youtube qui je trouve a vraiment été
excellent sur cet aspect dans ces vidéos
elle espère que j'avais cet épisode de
la prochaine fois on va continuer à
parler de la science telle qu'elle est
faite aujourd'hui en particulier on
parlera des tests randomisée en double
aveugle et de leur importance pour avoir
de bonnes conclusions scientifiques
éléments un petit peu d'erreurs et même
si vous avez aimé cet épisode spécial
laquelle augmenté à le partager pensez à
vous abonner pour une connerie futurs
épisodes martiaux type ford et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois
lorsqu on assemble deux ou davantage de
variables quelle sera la distribution de
probabilités de la nouvelle variable
c'est ici que les statisticiens ont
découvert quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
encore me fascine plus on assemble à
grand nombre de variables aléatoires
identiquement distribué par addition
plus la distribution de probabilités de
la nouvelle variable se rapproche d'une
distribution normale c'est ça le
théorème centrale limite
alors plutôt que de dire on sait pas
donc on s'en fout disons plutôt oui
effectivement il y à un certain degré
d'incertitude sur ce sujet donc essayons
d'ajuster nos crédence du mieux que nous
le pouvons avec les connaissances que
nous avons et s'il s'agit d'un sujet
important efforçons-nous d'acquérir de
nouvelles informations afin d'ajuster
nos crédence de façon plus rigoureuse